I was told the story it was I was about
20 years ago I was in my very early 25
21 years old and I was having an
argument with my then-partner about
whether or not gay people were political
anymore and this was during in the 1990s
there was another smaller miners strike
much smaller it was sort of the end of
the the Union and that industry being
closed down so there was a little tiny
miners strike going on and my
then-boyfriend was saying you know that
we ought to be supporting the miners and
I said why should i support the miners
they don't support me and he said well
let me tell you a story and he did he
didn't know much of the story but he was
a bit older he was 10 years older than
me which is what entitled him to talk
like he was Che Guevara I guess and he
said he'd been at the pride march where
the the mine has led the march so he'd
seen it I was I thought it would make a
wonderful film immediately as soon as
always you know because how could you
not really that's what I thought but but
apparently you it is possible to not see
that possibility because nobody else did
and also I was 21 so when you say to
someone you know I've had an idea for an
enormous British feature film about gay
and lesbian activists you don't they
don't tend to take you very seriously so
it took a long time for anyone people
said things like why don't you do it on
the radio why don't you do it as a
puppet show and you know nothing nobody
would would see but what I thought what
I felt was that there's the story the
treatment that the story required was
was should be related to the to what
happened so lgsm took what they did and
they're messaged into the mainstream and
that's why I felt very strongly it
should be a mainstream film and I felt
very strongly that what I didn't want to
do was make a film that would be not
that there's anything wrong with films
like this but that would be a good LGBT
film festivals all around the world and
that nobody else would see it I wanted
to make a film that belonged in the
mainstream because it's it's not a film
it's not a gay film in a sense that it's
it's about you know things that are very
universal even if had you been 40 years
old at that time had a little bit more
credits under your belt I suspect the
reaction would have been the same yeah
what were they when the people were
suggesting you do it it's a puppet
theater
as a radio play what was their concern
about the content even though this the
world in theory had changed since then
they would say things like you know
people don't ever say we can't make a we
won't spend that money on gays and
lesbians but they said things like it
would be very difficult to bring a
commercial audience to that story that
would that was the thing i was mostly
told and it and it is you know that's
that's that's true they're not wrong
about that that cake can be and I gave
up on it really after after a while
people said you know eventually I had a
general meeting this was you know so 20
years later and by then I had a play on
at the national theatre I was older I
was you know more established and I had
a bit more clout and I had a general
meeting with david livingstone the
producer and I just didn't even bring it
up he was pitching me some nice romantic
comedies and I was served sort of
deflecting them and then at the end of
the meeting I had my coat on and was I
was standing at the door and he said
slightly frustrated that I didn't want
to do any of his romantic comedies he
said are there any stories you're
burning to tell and it had just started
raining and I thought well I'm not going
to go out into the street so I might as
well tell him tell him the story of lgsm
and I said I now know this is the best
thing you can ever say in a pitch but at
the time I on a promise you it was
innocent and I think you can only do it
once but I said yes I said I have this
one story but nobody will ever make it
and it's kind of a challenge his sort of
vanity was you know anyway well I might
you know he'll is this a one mountain
that hasn't been fired yeah exactly it's
something sort of got to him all right
so I told him the story I mean I had to
really dredge it up because I hadn't
told you a little way both physically
and emotionally gone finished with
forget it had you even written it no I
hadn't written a word and I said um so I
told him the story is best i could
remember it it just sort of came back to
me as I went along and I found myself
going on yeah Wales yeah they went to
Wales and and I and I am and I finished
the story and I he was um like a lot of
us film people you know he's a
combination of ruthless and sentimental
so he I could see on one I he was
thinking that's an incredible
opportunity while the other I just had a
tier going down the sink and he said the
same thing that everyone always says
whenever I told the story which was is
that
true and I said yeah it's true and he
said and he said I'll Commission it wow
so you have kind of put it out of your
mind you know the story kind of end it's
bare bone details what kind of reference
is available what I mean there's not
been a book published about this did the
did the actual organizers of this keep
records they keep photographs to keep
videos what was more film what was
available to you though because it was a
pre google group yeah i mean i know this
is going to be a hard thing for people
to appreciate it was very hard to to
find anything at all what I did find
which was incredible they did make a
film of their own a video in 1985 which
I found weirdly because one of them Jeff
who is the character in the film who is
played by Freddie Fox he's the one at
the beginning was concerned he has a
love bite and that all the kids loved
him he was a sort of pin up at the
village he's now a Buddhist monk called
it apeksha Priya I mean you know don't
tell me that fact isn't stranger than
fiction and and on his website he had
put up her this this you know he put up
this little video so I watched it and it
was full of you know the story it was
full of the real people but because it
wasn't you know they were in and I mean
it's in the very best sense of the word
they were amateurs so they observed none
of the disciplines of documentary
filmmaking no names up on the screen so
when someone is interviewed they just
are interviewed you don't know who they
are or what they're doing or why they're
there so I basically watched this thing
over and over again and at the end of it
there was a credit card you know one
card with with thanks to and a list of
names and I thought well if I
cross-reference the most unusual names
on facebook I might you know though I
might find them you know I thought my
mum's on Facebook you know these guys
are gonna be in their 50s this has got
to work and there was someone on there
called Reggie blennerhassett they're
probably on only one winner house it's
gotta be only one and indeed and Barry
was well there was a picture of a
smiling middle-aged man on a yacht and I
sent him a message saying are you the
rent Reggie blennerhassett who was in
lgsm in 1984 and a message came straight
back and it he said I hadn't been asked
that question in 30 years what can you
possibly want and I told him and he said
yeah I'll meet you
Wow so when do you start talking to
these people and you have a picture in
your own mind of what happened what was
the big revelation of what actually
happened that kind of conflicted with
your understanding of what had happened
I think I always had a notion of I knew
that the mark that I knew that what i
thought was good i had this be I knew
that the group had started collecting
money at gay pride 84 and I knew that in
gay pride 85 a couple hundred miners
came and marched so I had that so I knew
I had a beginning in an end and I really
thought I'll just have to pad the middle
out a bit you know I put in a love story
or maybe you know someone could die you
know the way you do and and but then as
I started to research and I started to
talk to them I realized that there would
be absolutely no padding necessary the
more I mean for example watching the the
video there was a young woman in their
25 year old young mother housewife and
the way that she talked to the camera
the way she engaged with the camera and
the way that she answered questions it
just was someone with a fierce intellect
working-class what young working clothes
woman with a fierce intellect and a
fierce curiosity about the world and she
was so charismatic and I said to one of
the guys that I was talking to first
person I spoke to before Reggie because
he was on holiday at found someone else
and he couldn't really remember very
much about it but we watched the video
together on i would say who's that who's
that who's there and this young woman
was then he said oh yeah that's Sean he
said I think something happened to her I
said okay write something good and he
said yeah she became she maybe was on
the town council so I thought well
that's a great story and then I googled
her name and saw that she had become an
MP ah it surpassed the town council and
was now one of the lawmakers in the
mother of all Parliament's so yeah that
I know yeah things like that just went
you know I realized at that point that
the story was just going to keep
yielding there are I guess a four
different kinds of ways to look at the
story you have the story about the
collaboration from these two disparate
groups you have a story of this one
young man kind of coming out and
discovering himself you have the birth
of the AIDS epidemic as your kind of
trying to figure out which of those four
poles to focus on how does one way over
the other
and what was the balancing act that you
tried to strike between those stories
yeah I think a story of Joe and was as I
was writing was in the foreground the
most and Joe is a character I created
that character in order to give the
audience a hand into the screen really
because the you know the past is a
foreign country and and I think for an
audience sitting there thinking I don't
know anything about gay and lesbian life
in 1980s London or no do I know anything
about trade unionism in Wales you know
neither does he so he's the person who
can ask all the questions and I think
because I didn't know when I said first
wrote the screenplay he featured very
heavily his story features very heavily
and then I came to a point rifle why am
I focusing on this made-up story that is
a very interesting set in the suburbs
when I've got this incredible true
stories and that that was pulled right
back it's 30 years after the fact today
earlier in Los Angeles there's thousands
of people marching in the aids walk I'm
curious even though this movie is a
period film in some ways what do you
think it's modern relevance is and what
do you hope people take away from this
story it's interesting because also you
know living in living in in metropolitan
liberal cities it can be easy for us to
to forget how in so many other parts of
the world or even parts of the country
life is very different for people who
are different LGBT but specifically but
I suppose in terms of what the intention
was I wanted to do a couple of things
really mostly related to young people i
wanted to because lgsm were young i mean
their average age was 24 I wanted to I
wanted to present a group of people
young LGBT people to other young LGBT
people in a film that was not about sex
where it wasn't about you know about
that because I it concerns me that for
so much about the LGBT community is
focused on sit on sex and sexuality and
there is so much more to us into life
and you know and also that I think it
concerns me the young LGBT people learn
that their only value is sexual what you
know when they when they arrive when
they come out and I think that's
dangerous rizal and also I wanted to
show what happens in lgsm the reason why
it was a success I think is because
it was such a game changer it's because
they showed up and we live in an age now
where you know you can click and you can
be an activist you know remotely and
virtually and you can link with
thousands people all over the world in
all kinds of ways but there is nothing
there is unfortunately no substitute or
no fortunately not unfortunately there
is no substitute for the act of standing
and facing somebody face-to-face and
shaking their hand and saying Here I am
to support you bodily here physically
and it's that which made the difference
it's that which made the difference to
that eroded the prejudice in Wales and
that made the difference for lgsm so I
wanted to kind of say that's import we
have to keep doing that we have to keep
showing its boots on the ground and also
with the character of Joe there's a
scene in the film where you see him
running into his bedroom and he throws
his old childish records down on the bed
discards them and he's got you know he's
looks better and he's puts up the
stranglers and your rib mix and the
message of that scene really for young
people is if you get involved in
activism any activism at all but if you
get involved in life in politics your
clothes will improve your music will
improve and you will get laid and I
can't think of if that isn't going to
get them to do it I don't know what well